how many pillars are there in the prayer
what are the mandatory actions of all if
we don't know the answers to these
questions i hate to break it to you but
we have failed our duties but not to
worry because now with a click of a
button you can access our ever growing
online library at critical content you
can learn the basics of the arabic
language
and many many more you can do it click
on the link below
and subscribe now
brothers and sisters and dear friends
hope you guys are having a blessed
ramadan inshallah and using this
opportunity to come to come closer to uh
your lord inshallah and making the most
out of inshallah brothers and sisters
may allah bless every single one of you
guys do not forget i'm trying to raise
for 500 000 meals for people in yemen
afghanistan syria um and different
places promises please give to that
let's get straight into the topic in
charlotte and sisters
as you guys know there's been some
controversy regarding uh mufti mink um
and um i just wanted to bring some
light to it shed some light to it now
look i'm not
i'm not i made a minion of the ummah i'm
not somebody that needs to do videos
like this i don't find the need to do it
i don't look forward to doing it i
really don't even have time to do it
i'll be honest with you so i don't want
people to think you know i'm just
jumping on bandwagons etc you know or
just controversial stuff but sometimes
when i look at a situation i hear news
and if it's somebody i know i don't know
me personally i like to defend the
honour of any believer whoever it is
i don't have exclusivity to individuals
who i benefit from or not okay i don't
work like that i'm not somebody who's
like okay i benefit from this person
therefore let me defend this person
whoever knows me knows that i don't work
like that i don't care who it is what it
is i've turned my i wouldn't say my back
but i've gone against people who had
great benefit in my life that i could
have benefited financially in many
different ways but when i felt like they
were wrong i had to tell them they're
wrong and even if it came at the cost of
me cost of me losing financial benefits
or whatever it may be i don't really
care about that if somebody is wrong
they're wrong
so now let's get into this whole matter
guys here i'm going to be talking about
things that
have been taken out of context then
we'll look at in context and then we're
going to look at from our context what
do i mean by that now guys
as we know al jazeera has made
headlines about mufti meng that he
himself um was sitting down with a rabbi
who was pro-zionist acts pro-zionist
yeah we know exactly what that means you
know these child killers you know that's
that's what they are baby killers
land stealers you know and the list goes
on you know an apartheid state that
they're pushing forward to
so you know how it is you know you've
seen our campaigns last year uh after
they killed 66 innocent children
so the thing is now they've made it as
if
mufti mink has gone there
willingly knowingly participating
with an individual who is pro-zionist
now this is out of context
because i have spoken to brother dele
may allah bless him from five pillars
which i'm going to come to later i've
spoken to mufti bank i've read the
articles
i've asked some really direct questions
to move to make myself may allah bless
him you know because i wanted
clarifications for myself as well you
know i'm not just going to jump on
something i just i want to know i have
direct contact i'm going to do that so
it is very very clear guys that it is
out of context so al jazeera made a
headline which is out of context okay
now let's come to what is in context now
guys there's only one part of the
picture used where muftimenk is sitting
next to the rabbi
now from that it does look like
he's gone there what excuse could there
be
now when you look at other pictures and
videos guys you will realize that there
was hundreds if not thousands of people
there which i have confirmed
and on the left hand side of muftimenk
there is a sikh man with the turbine
sitting there there was also christians
there was also hindus and other
religious groups there so we need to
make something very very clear
and i asked this move to make myself i
said mufti was you aware that this
person
was was there or was going to be there
or was you invited for this uh specific
is this specific uh specifically like
you know um you know we are trying to
normalize effects with
um zionist
or israel and we want you to come okay
now he said it very categorically in
this video himself that no he didn't
know
he did not know guys so now one thing
that we need to bear in context is the
following okay we can say you know what
maybe he should have done some due
diligence he should have looked he
should have known
now as a public figure maybe not as
known as popular as a mufti mink and we
ask allah to make us famous in the
heavens
in this dunya
the point is this guys
yes you guys have expectations of us but
we have a life where it's so so so
hectic so hectic guys
so you need to understand we are not
super human beings yeah neither are we
infallible so you need to understand
that there are certain things we make
mistakes of this is an easy mistake that
we can look past because you need to
understand the event that he's gone to
has multiple individuals group of people
from different faith groups
if the
event was just where there's jews
and muslims
we would be saying some of the main
muslim men didn't that look a bit fishy
when you go into an iftar event a
ramadan event yeah an opportunity to
give tawa and you see people from
different faith groups nobody is ever
going to think this is a event to
normalize relationships with zionists or
israel because it doesn't look like that
the theme is not that so let's make that
category clear so in context number one
he didn't know
number two the event itself is not even
something that you can be i mean it
sounds a bit fishy because if you say
multi if it's a
event regarding different faiths you are
bound to expect a rabbi there you are
bound to i mean let's be honest guys
let's be honest
if there was no christians there was no
sikhs there was no hindus or whatever
and it was just
jewish rabbis
then i would be like
you know that was fishy i mean maybe you
should have found that before you went
but he's going to an event where it's
categorically clear it's a dinner it's
ramadan event you know whatever it may
be and there is multiple different
groups of faith groups there so
now that is in context so look that out
of context context we looked at it from
in context now look at it from our
context your context do you guys believe
that mufti men
was told
you are coming to an event
where there will be a pro-zionist
israeli
sitting right next to you
and we are doing this to normalize
affairs
do you believe muftimenk from your
context from your perspective
he would say yes to that or do you think
he would say no to that now if you ask
me that question
i would say he would
categorically say
no to that
now i have no reason
to believe mufti meng will say yes to
that
so the question i want to ask which is
the following things which i want to do
is now talk about backstabbers those who
are frustrated sincere individuals
and those who are blind followers i want
to break it down into three groups these
categories because that's what we're
kind of working with we know of the men
to be yanni actually one brother put it
you know he's he's like the ronaldo of
the muslim mode and he's he's one of the
biggest guys it's not is his biggest day
out there and he does amazing work
have we seen evil from him no have we
seen bad from him no have we seen
question marks on him no
so now as a believer what is my
responsibility towards another believer
that i see good in
is that i have to assume the best
minimum minimum
this doesn't mean that when i see things
which are like really efficient i'm like
no
and then
assuming the best who's not done should
be given to to a great limit like the
salaf would say if we saw our brother
drenched in alcohol you guys know we
would say somebody pulled it down his
head if you saw him in a mountain saying
i am your your lord and you are my slave
will say he's reciting an eye of the
quran
guys the point is this
they should be done we need to learn how
to have good assumptions allah says in
the quran
um
verse 12 all believers avoid many
suspicion for indeed some suspicion is
sinful and do not say nor back by one
another would any of you like to eat the
flesh of their brother you would despise
that and fear allah surely allah is the
uh allah accepts the repentance and he's
the most merciful guys so now
i want to talk about backstabbers yeah a
couple of months ago i personally had
this okay
where i done a video against enclave
enemy of islam somebody who rips the
quran installs the prophet night and day
and i had a i wouldn't even call it a
debate etc you know but there was the
way i conducted myself was a bit cringy
yeah it was a bit it was not needed yeah
it was not the way i conduct myself was
not the best way not that he caught me
in any arguments not he made any valley
point valid points that guy couldn't
even
uh sort of
that's how pathetic it was
but
the very next day the very next date is
as if somebody these these individuals
and
literal opportunistic backstabbers
the guy didn't wait one day he edited a
video recording and released it
attacking me and not only attacking me
defending the guy defending the guy that
i've apparently slandered him yeah
now these kind of individuals are
backstabbers opportunistic backstabbers
who are these people these are people
who are waiting for your mistake
they are looking
how can i catch him when can i catch him
yeah this is the approach they have
that's why i call them as opportunistic
backstabbers that's what they are they
have a disease in the heart i'll tell
you very categorically these people hate
you more than they hate enemies of islam
their hatred to you is so greater than
the enemies of islam that they have no
problem the moment they see your fall
down
attack attack they don't think another
believer yeah like we know the concept
in islam that the worst of believer is
better than the best of the disbeliever
and this is this is from our religion
it's as simple as that why because of
tahiti not from because of raised money
or no no because of la illahi
yeah and you have this group of
individuals uh you have this group of
individuals basically they hate you
like
i'm saying the attitude is that
was known to attack severely towards the
believers like allah says in the quran
be soft towards the believers and harsh
towards the disbelievers while we're
talking about combatants enemies yeah
these guys flip it
opposite total opposite yeah
now al jazeera to me fits in that sorry
it's like an opportunistic backstabber
to come and do that
now second category was why we said
backstabbers and those who are frustrate
sincere frustrated muslims they are
brothers now i believe brother dele
hussain from five pillars may allah
bless him i know him
last ramadan of the year before i used
to do uber i think i dropped the
customers i went there and ate with him
and he called me this house i had uh
okay may allah bless him how i am
assuming the best in mufti in that
situation i have to assume the best in
delhi as well now mufti meng doesn't
know dilly so it's understandable that
he's upset and he has a right to be
upset because the title of five pillars
i personally
would have not agreed with because it it
was kind of misrepresented i'm not
saying anybody did it on purpose i also
understand where brother de la hussein
is coming from with the frustration
what's going on in palestine and the
vulnerable oppression they're doing
sometimes in my country they say
when you get up with anger and you sit
you sit down with a loss so the thing is
where brother hussein was coming from is
understandable maybe
you know muffy man and he did say that
he tried to get in contact with him
privately okay which is shows me
sincerity yeah and he did in his video
mention how much he does love mufti mang
and his videos etc and i do believe what
mufti menk um you know he expressed you
know he was upset et cetera i think was
more targeted towards al jazeera rather
than uh brother uh
himself because he doesn't know him okay
it's understandable when these things
happen we're human beings you know when
when it comes across like that it seems
like that but i genuinely believe
brother hussein was genuinely just
frustrated that to see what the united
arab
em normalizing relationships with um
with israel he was frustrated and
someone like muftimenko plays obviously
a massive role uh
a massive role in the muslim community
and has a massive influence obviously to
him maybe it was frustrating
and it was just something maybe done
without maybe great thought in both
parts just as we if we think okay must
dementia of thought about it before
doing even though i
i don't think there's any blame on him
because he didn't know i think the same
could be said about brother daley
hussain that maybe he had done the
article without maybe giving it a deeper
thought you know
so i want to say that brothers really i
believe is sincere and he done it out of
concern and that's it i don't think he
has anything against brother uh mufti
men and neither do i would would even
class them anywhere near backs of
opportunistic person i wouldn't i would
far away from that now
another issue is this guys okay
mufti meng if he doesn't know if i don't
know somebody guys if i sit down with
hitler and i eat food
and i don't know nothing about hitler i
don't know who the hell hitler is okay
and people like oh my gosh he did this
he did that how could you
i don't know who he is
like i don't know who i did not know who
he is why are you blaming me for
something i did not know
i don't know subhanallah allah says in
the quran we will not destroy nation
until we send the messenger so at least
they know and then be judged how can we
judge someone when they did not know
now lastly i want to address the blind
followers now the blind followers go
with myself and anyone that's a public
figure sometimes we defend somebody and
i'm not saying there's anything wrong
with that but we defend him even if he's
wrong and i'm not trying to say move him
anyone's wrong because i made it
categorically clear that it was in his
fault he did not know it's as simple as
that
but the thing is this guy's
we need to also not attack somebody else
that for example you know brother dilly
was also been getting attacked etc look
guys we also need to be like okay you
know what maybe the title was wrong but
we should not go and attack them back by
slander you know just because we really
love someone it's understandable i
understand i have people that love the
work that i do but sometimes when i see
them being unjust to someone just
because of who i am i'm like don't do
that because you've been on just here so
just for the blind followers of anybody
let's just be careful uh that we do not
you know put love someone to such a
point that we become unjust it's not
fair and in a nutshell guys i just want
to end with that it's as simple as that
that's my two pence piece look i'm a
nobody it's just i'm just trying to make
things and put things into context like
i said before it's every muslim
believer's job to assume the best it's
as simple as that guys it's not really
hard to do and somebody who does good
work we have to assume the best
inshallah and like i said before i know
mufti meng i know him personally and i
know very categorically if he was told
this is a zionist guy who's trying to
normalize relationships between united
arab emirates and
israel et cetera i know he's going to
say no and he's made it very clear that
he stands for the palestinian
palestinian cause it's as simple as that
from sisters and um that's it that's all
i have to say i can't log out anymore
that's why i said do you agree you don't
agree give me a two pence piece there um
not that will change my opinion my
opinion like like i said before it's
very clear i looked into the matter etc
and i'm seeing both sides people are
attacking somebody attacking them off to
make something attacking daily saying
etc please guys it's ramadan we're in
ramadan for god's sake okay let's take a
step back let's just relax inshallah um
and let's assume the best in brother
dilli as much as we should also assume
the best in mufti mink we should do that
one says inshallah and maybe even in
this video if you disagree with me might
assume the best it's as simple as it's
not damn hard just assume the best for
god's sake it will save you so much
problems till next time brothers and
sisters inshallah i hope i haven't
missed anything else out if i have
forgive me inshallah and if i have done
if this video is caused upset somebody i
apologize i genuinely don't want to i
just want harmony and peace in the
muslim ummah inshallah and may allah
keep us firm and make the most out of
ramadan inshallah until next time
assalamualaikum